معركه باخموت التي اشعلت الشتاء الاوكراني
باتت تحمل الرمزيه الاكبر في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني
المدينه التي تسمى ايضا
تقع شرقيه اوكرانيا شماليه اقليم دونيتس
تحديدا والذي تتقاسم القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه السيطره عليه القتال الدموي
المستمر منذ اشهر في المدينه والذي حمل
تقدم الروسيا في الايام الاخيره ادى الى
قطع الطرق المؤديه اليها باستثناء طريق
وحيده تصل الى الغرب سلطات دنيا المواليه
لروسيا تزعم ان القوات الروسيه استطاعت
السيطره على نصف المدينه محققه تقدما من
الجهتين الشماليه والجنوبيه
قتال مستميد تراه موسكو ذا اهميه
استراتيجيه كبيره للتوغل باتجاه الغرب
الذي تسيطر عليه كييف خاصه وان الهدف
التالي سيكون المدينتين المفتاحتين
كراماتورسك وسلفيانك
المدينه مركزا دفاعيا مهما للقوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه دومباس والسيطره
عليها ستسمح بها هجمات اضافيه في عمق خطوط
الدفاع القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه لكن رغم
كل هذه الاهميه من وجهه النظر الروسيه فان
واشنطن تقصر اهميه المدينه على الناحيه
الرمزيه وليس الاستراتيجيه وتؤكد ان
التقدم الروسي فيها لن يعني تغيير مسار
المعركه الى عمر العربيه